jennifer lopez once said
[Music]
but what about the price of fame
it was an adjustment period uh the
losing of the privacy and everything was
definitely the hardest thing to get used
to with becoming someone who's in the
public eye
yeah benefer is used to all eyes on them
but that doesn't mean they have to be
okay with invasions of privacy like this
recent leak from their wedding in
georgia tmz posting a video of jlo
serenading ben affleck at their
reception
in the clip jen appears to sing a new
song complete with backup dancers and
ben grins from ear to ear over his new
bride's performance
he's never been happier i've seen that
dude be happy but the pure joy that was
like radiating from his face
is was absolutely unforgettable is
honestly one of the like 10 sweetest
precious most precious moments i've ever
witnessed in my life sweet but meant to
stay private jen revealed on instagram
that the video getting out was a total
betrayal by one of her own wedding
guests the singer dropped into the
comments section of a fan page that
reposted her performance saying quote
this was taken without permission period
and whoever did it took advantage of our
private moment she explains guest signed
ndas and knew not to post about the
wedding on social media jen's clapback
continued this was stolen without our
consent and sold for money she also
calls out her newsletter on the jlo
saying anything she and ben want to
share from their big day will be
released on that platform
[Music]
she gave followers a first look at her
three wedding looks the day after their
georgia ceremony she also took fans
inside her and ben's vegas allotment
back in july
you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
and let's not forget when she opened up
about ben's proposal
it was totally unexpected
my love came in ben came in and he got
down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
and he hands me a ring
and he said it's a green diamond my
favorite color hopefully their wedding
day video leak doesn't damper the happy
couple's memories from their big day
yeah it was absolutely beautiful uh you
know she's got impeccable taste so the
whole wedding looks fantastic
beautifully appointed flawless and they
were happy you could tell like they
worked hard to get here they earned it
and it was so nice man they had a great
day for us
[Music]
you